osteoarthritis of the thumb also known
as basal joint arthritis is a problem
with the joint at the base of your thumb
smooth cartilage covering the bones in
your joint has worn away causing pain
and other symptoms
there is no cure for osteoarthritis and
it usually gets worse over time
but treatments that don't require
surgery can help relieve symptoms in the
early stages for example you can put ice
on the joint several times a day
pinching with your thumb may increase
the stress on the joint and result in
more pain
to help reduce your pain your healthcare
provider may give you tips on how to
change the way you pinch or grasp
objects
you may also be advised to wear a splint
to limit movement this allows the joint
some time to rest and heal
medicines such as acetaminophen can help
reduce pain non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs such as
ibuprofen or aspirin can help reduce
both pain and swelling
you may also receive a steroid injection
directly into your joint to reduce the
swelling and provide pain relief
if you have questions about
osteoarthritis of the thumb or which
treatment option may be best for you
talk to your health care provider